wie ich weiß ich nicht ich
weiß noch wie ich bei dem sofa
sendung wo ich dabei den content
trällern durfte so vormann war das vor
23 jahren auf dem sofa irgendwo gestand
bin ich oft ein sofa gestiegen und weiß
ich weiß hat irgendwelche blöden sprüche
da die ich ja nicht drauf habe so wie du
vom stapel gelassen ich hoffe du bist
mir nicht gerade deswegen danach habe
ich wirklich schlechtes gewissen haben
aber gesagt er im grundwasser scheiße
das ist ein richtig guter da kann ich
daran kann ich nicht klingen und ich
sollte mich nicht in deinen bereich
irgendwie versteigert darin versteigern
versteigen dass ich dir paroli bieten
könnte kann ich nicht er ist einfach ein
großer lieber jürgen da musste ich durch
das ganze leben lang gremium weil du nur
sprüche macht nein jürgen ist ein das
muss ich sagen also dass der sie noch
hält egal auf welche art und weise essen
riesen entertainer es riesen jürgen du
bist wer hinter den du hast du bist 40
jahre im geschäft oder sowas bis immer
noch so drauf ganz egal was alle sagen
bleib wo bitte bleibt uns als original
erhalten es gibt nur noch wenige und ich
finde ein bett im kornfeld glaube ich
habe schon tausend mal karikiert oder so
was du hast mir wirklich vorlagen
geliefert um mass mit deinen allein mit
seiner physischen präsenz und dann dem
was du sagst kann ein ganzes programm
machen und das ist ja auch ein großer
wert also wie gesagt